organizaciones sociales convocan marchas
en todo colombia unas marchas que
demuestran que el llamado paro nacional
está lejos de concluir
después de tres semanas de
movilizaciones continuas el diálogo
entre los sindicatos y el gobierno de
iván duque está estancado a pesar de las
reuniones entre ambas partes todavía no
se ha instalado una mesa de negociación
los líderes sindicales denuncian que no
hay diálogo posible mientras el gobierno
no reconozca su responsabilidad en las
muertes de manifestantes a manos de la
policía y desmilitarice en las ciudades
más de 40 personas han muerto durante
las protestas desde el 28 de abril y ese
proceso no ha podido arrancar porque
ahora el gobierno no acepta otro asunto
supremamente importante parar la
violencia que desató desde el 28
parar esa violencia contra el legítimo
derecho a la protesta tú que estás lejos
de dejar de recurrir a la fuerza pública
para hacer frente a las protestas
recientemente anunció el máximo
despliegue de las fuerzas de seguridad
para desbloquear las vías que siguen
cortadas por los manifestantes en varios
puntos del país mientras tanto anunció
algunas medidas sociales no negociadas
con los convocantes del paro empezaremos
a partir del próximo primero de julio un
programa de generación de empleo juvenil
que empieza con subsidiar el equivalente
al 25 por ciento del salario mínimo
legal mensual unas medidas que no son
suficientes para las organizaciones que
ni siquiera representan la totalidad de
las protestas